قدم اخصائيه الصحه العقليه بعض النصائح
لتحسين نفسك في اشهر الشتاء من الاضطراب
العاطفي الموسمي اولها السماح بدخول اشعه
الشمس فحتى عندما تكون ايام رماديه وبدر
جهدا للسماحي بدخول الضوء وافتح اي ستائر
للسماح بدخول اكبر قدر ممكن منه استخدم
العلاج بالضوء عبر مصابيح اس اي دي وهي
عباره عن ضوء اصطناعي يمكن ان يخدع الدماغ
لاطلاق مواد كيميائيه تعزيز الحاله
المزاجيه تحديد اولويات الانشطه المجدوله
فعندما يكون جو باردا ومظلما قد يكون من
الصعب العثور على الدافع لذا حدد اوقات
محدد القيام بالانشطه وحاول تضمين الاخرين
حتى يصعب التراجع عنها في اللحظه الاخيره
حافظ على ممارسه الرياضه لتخفيف من التراب
العاطفي الموسمي فعندما ممارسه الرياضه
نظام غذائي صحي ومتوازن هذا يعد خطوه
ايجابيه يمكنك اتخاذها للتحكم في التراب
العاطفي الموسمي فاكد ايضا من شرب كميات
كافيه من الماء طوال اليوم للحفاظ على
نشاطك